al obvio de presidentes en 21 años la
muestra de una convulsa realidad
política en perú en noviembre de 2002
eventos ocurrían en tokio y lima de
manera casi paralela mientras el
entonces presidente alberto fujimori
renunciaba el congreso lo destituía
argumentando actos de corrupción e
incapacidad moral permanente tras la
salida de fujimori el presidente del
congreso o valentín paniagua asumió de
manera interina como mandatario unos
meses después el opositor alejandro
toledo ganó las elecciones a toledo lo
sucedería en julio de 2006 el ex
presidente alan garcía pero tras dos
años al mando su gabinete tuvo que
renunciar para impedir la aprobación de
un voto de censura en el congreso por
recibir pagos a cambio de concesiones a
la compañía noruega discover petroleum
en junio de 2011 el militar retirado de
izquierda ollanta humala ganó por un
estrecho margen a la hija del ex
presidente alberto fujimori keiko y se
convirtió así en el primer gobernante
izquierdista en perú en 36 años en 2016
keiko fujimori perdió de nuevo unas
elecciones presidenciales esta vez ante
el ex banquero de wall street- pedro
pablo kuczynski
a la derrota a su partido consiguió una
amplia mayoría en el congreso
legislatura terminó con la renuncia de
kuczynski por posibles acuerdos con los
fujimoristas para indultar al ex
presidente tras ello llegó martín
vizcarra en septiembre de 2019 vizcarra
disolvió el congreso y en octubre keiko
fujimori fue enviada a prisión
preventiva 2020 sería el año de los
juicios políticos en septiembre el
congreso aprobó una moción para
destituir a vizcarra por presuntos
contratos irregulares con un cantante
pero poco después de salir airoso
comenzó el proceso de noviembre donde
finalmente se aprobó su destitución tras
ello fue investido manuel merino que
duró sólo cinco días en el cargo en
medio de intensas protestas desatadas
tras una moción de censura vizcarra que
parte de la población entendió como
fraudulenta el 17 de noviembre sería
investido francisco sagasti y tercer
presidente de perú en una semana y
último hasta las pasadas elecciones de
abril